le musée départemental maurice denis
fait sa rentrée avec une nouvelle
exposition mettant les femmes à
l'honneur un grand de richesse de cette
disposition c'est qu'on mélange à la
fois des artistes extrêmement connue
comme denis et beaubien
mais également des artistes femme
entièrement nue méconnu qui dans leur
vie ont été retenues en tant que fidh en
tant que femme de et qu'aujourd'hui on
remet à l'honneur en tant qu'artiste
peintre qui était pourtant souvent leur
activité principale
intitulé femmes avec un ace elle se
décompose en cinq parties femme modèle
mère artiste parfois des corps et aimé
[Musique]
les amateurs d'art pourront ainsi
admirer les portraits des femmes de
maurice denis mais également le travail
de ses élèves ou de sa fille un des
chefs d'oeuvre de cette exposition il
s'agit du portrait de alice 7 par theo
van rysselberghe
et on a cette touche 30 liste absolument
phénoménal dans ce tableau les visiteurs
pourront découvrir cette exposition
jusqu'au 2 juillet 2023 au total elle
regroupe une quarantaine d'oeuvres
issues essentiellement des collections
du musée certaines peintures sont
d'ailleurs présentés au public pour la
première fois
[Musique]